[Musique]
imaginez une ville de plus de 12
millions d'habitants une population qui
consomme à un raid m'affole une mégapole
où il n'existe pourtant aucun programme
de recyclage officiel quelques petits
centres de tri mais encore doit-on les
trouver il faut être drôlement motivé
pour recycler ses ordures à moscou et
tous les moyens sont bons pour convertir
le moscow ce matin l'om j'espère
écologique offre des billets gratuits
pour le théâtre et le viser en échange
des ordures ménagères problème au genou
gauche le 10 la hausse beaumont on a
fait ça pour attirer l'attention des
citoyens pour que la planète ne soit
plus la grande poubelle qu'elle est
devenue à l'extérieur les choses tombent
dessus
j'ai pris la décision de filtrer mes
déchets parce que mes beaux parents
habitent juste à côté de nous des
montagnes d'ordures et chaque fois que
j'y passe ça me fait peur
c'est en effet une véritable catastrophe
écologique qui se déroule dans la caisse
et la différence du gouvernement russe
ces montages artificiels sont les
ordures accumulées et elles sont
devenues la norme en banlieue de la
capitale
hollywood en l'absence de réglementation
c'est crime organisé qui s'était qu'à
part et l'industrie il leur a fallu en
arriver là
des odeurs putrides et même des
intoxications pour que les citoyens
sortent dans la rue
désespérée pour demander au gouvernement
de trouver une solution
aujourd'hui ceux qui recyclent le font
grâce au bouche à oreille about you want
is you mister celio igor est membre
d'une petite armée de bénévoles avec sa
camionnette il arpente les quartiers
résidentiels
alors on est dans l'est de moscou igor
attend une cliente qui lui a signifié
par internet qu'elle allait venir
déposer du recyclage et toute la journée
ils passent au travers des laisses à un
rythme assez freiné et tout ça comme
bénévole il suffit de le suivre quelques
heures pour constater à quel point les
russes n'y connaissent rien
malgré toute la bonne volonté
à kouba
bon soldat moi j'essaierai d'être notre
état participerait plus au recyclage
alors moi je le fais pour avoir la
conscience tranquille
[Musique]
sa récolte est acheminée si l usine
plastre source à 100 km de mourom
d'affaires et demie bogoliubov s'est
lancé dans la gestion des déchets ya
trois ans à ses risques et périls
shaqiri d'internet au cht au registre et
niort ce qui m'a choqué c'est qu'il n'y
avait aucune organisation tout était
contrôlé par la mafia il n'y avait pas
une seule règle et aucun organisme
officiel
ici on recycle tous les types de déchets
plastiques ses revenus proviennent
exclusivement des matières traitées qui
sont ensuite revendus qui était au
départ une opportunité d'affaires est de
nouveau cassé j'ai rencontré des
écologistes j'ai commencé à participer à
des séminaires
si les affaires vont bien et jenny
s'inquiète du sort des petites
compagnies verte comme la sienne alors
que le gouvernement russe s'apprête à
s'approprier la gestion des déchets à
traiter les cas coach autre chose car il
ya un proverbe russe qui dit on a voulu
faire pour le mieux mais on a fait comme
d'habitude c'est exactement ce qui
arrive avec le dossier des déchets hier
le gouvernement prévoit désormais
construire 5 et 6 nérac
angers 1
moscou deux bras à temps pour son propre
fonds de recyclage
[Musique]